imagínate que un día vas caminando por
la calle se te acerca a alguien y te
dice mira te voy a poner un desafío
quiero que construyas un triángulo con
lados con lados de longitudes 22 y 5 la
pregunta es podrás construir este
triángulo o no bueno pues vamos a
intentar lo que tendría que pasar para
que el triángulo tuviera lados 2 2 y 5
bueno para empezar debe tener un lado
que mida 5 entonces déjame tomar ese 5 y
lo voy a poner por acá este es un
segmento de longitud 5 vale 5 y luego
que tendría que suceder para que los
otros dos segmentos los otros dos lados
del triángulo me dan 2 y 2
bueno pues uno de los lados debe estar
pegado aquí verdad y debe de medir 2
voy a trazar un poco mas derechito estoy
aquí debe de medir 2 y otro debe estar
pegado aquí y también debe medir 2
entonces quedaría como por acá digamos y
debe medir 2
y en realidad pues podríamos seguir
jugando un poco para ver si se puede o
no construir un triángulo y realmente lo
que nos gustaría es que ahora este
extremo quede conectado con este extremo
de acá así que podemos ir rotando estas
longitudes rotando estas longitudes
haciendo que siempre queden de longitud
dos y ver qué sucede pero incluso aunque
las rotemos hasta llegar al segmento de
longitud 5 no se van a tocar porque
cuando lleguen aquí abajo esto de acá va
a medir dos esto de acá también va a
medir dos y va a faltar
una unidad para que se toquen vale
entonces aquí no existe el triángulo
entonces este reto sería un reto
imposible lo voy a poner aquí
posible si de hecho para que en un
triángulo podamos hacer esto podamos
juntar estos dos segmentos necesitamos
que la suma de cualesquiera dos lados le
gane al último le gané al tercero y le
tiene que ganar estrictamente si si no
le gané estrictamente si la suma de los
dos lados es igual a este de acá
entonces tendríamos un triángulo
degenerado déjame hacer este ejemplo de
este lado por ejemplo si tuviéramos que
los lados que se buscan son 2 2 y 4
entonces ahora aquí tendríamos un
segmento de longitud 4 y los otros dos
lados tendrían que verse más o menos así
los voy a poner en color rosa tenían que
ser así de de longitud 2 y 2 2 y 2
digamos y ahora tendríamos otra vez que
rotar los verdad mirarlos para acá y
para acá y lo que sucede es que justo
cuando llegan a este segmento se encima
en verdad porque aquí queda 12 aquí 2
entonces este punto coincide con este de
acá pero sucede que entonces estos
ángulos justo son 0 y en realidad
nuestro triángulo no se ve
un triángulo sino como un segmento
entonces este este pues no es tanto un
triángulo bueno si es un triángulo pero
se le conoce como un triángulo
degenerado de g
negra
degenerado entonces para tener un
triángulo normal necesitamos que la suma
de cualesquiera dos lados le gane al
tercero y por supuesto si esto sucede
podemos dibujar nuestro triángulo por
ejemplo definitivamente podemos dibujar
un triángulo con lados 3 3 y 5 y para
hacerlo hacemos exactamente lo mismo
trazamos el lado de longitud 5 por aquí
5 y luego tomamos en los extremos
segmentos de longitud 3 digamos para
cada mide 3 ibaka mide tres para cada
digamos como por ahí mide tres y ahora
podemos empezar a cerrar estos segmentos
acercarlos hacia este de longitud 5 y en
algún momento antes de que lleguen hasta
acá se van a tocar se van a tocar
digamos ahí y vamos a poder construir
nuestro triángulo de la 2 3 3 y 5 y
sabemos que eso tiene que pasar porque
cuando bajan totalmente cuando bajan
totalmente aquí llegan a unos puntos
como a este punto de acá de aquí para
acá y de acá para acá y entonces ahí se
enciman entonces en algún momento
gusto tenían que tocarse estos dos vale
y una última pregunta que es interesante
es si éste es el único triángulo que
podemos hacer y realmente si es el único
verdad justamente tenemos que ver dónde
se ponen tocan estos dos puntos y el
único punto sería este de acá o el
simétrico aquí abajo pero en realidad
esos dos triángulos son congruentes
todos los triángulos que podemos hacer
con la 2 3 3 y 5 son exactamente iguales